topic with six innings the last time out
when he's at the bottom of the zone when
he's below the zone and when he's
living on the edges of the zone that's
when he's successful
the numbers don't match he's had a
couple of relief appearances thrown in
there that really throw those numbers
off so
he's been better since he's been back in
the rotation hopefully he's able to
locate
and get a lot of ground balls he's
sinker slider the two dominant pitches
the yankees will see from dobneck
tonight
chopper poured short simmons flips
and makes the play and dabnet gets the
ground ball off and out and if he is on
he will get a lot of those that's what i
was just gonna say when that's what it
looks like when it's right it's it's
balls that are topped by hitters and
it's balls that are kind of beating into
the ground and
simmons makes a difficult play look easy
you see him make that exchange low and
throw from that same arm slot
this play is not as easy as this guy
makes it look good start for dominant
here's aaron judge
and the count owen two this judge drives
that to left field
goodbye baron judge puts the yankees on
the board in the first
with home run number 15. watch dobneck's
reaction here
you think a pitcher doesn't know right
away boy when the slider
is up like that aaron judge will take
advantage
in a hurry one to nothing gary cole this
will be his 13th start on the year
6-3 record 2.26 era and you see the
thing that jumps off
the page for me is only 11 walks we know
he can strike out a lot of guys but
really that kind of control
with that kind of power really
remarkable one out and here comes
donaldson
josh donaldson earlier in the week
specifically
named garrett cole when expressing how
he felt there had to be a crackdown on
the sticky substances pitchers are using
best thing garrett cole can do is just
get him out round one belongs to cole
and at the end correct me if i'm wrong a
little chapman dubstep and a staring at
donaldson maybe
but excellent curveball that donaldson
misses by a lot i think garrett is fully
equipped to handle anything
cruz went around inning over cole fans
two
in a scoreless first including donaldson
one and two on gardner
gardner slaps that into left center that
ball is going to get down
then go to the wall rounding third is
higashiyoka
no throw home it's an rbi double
for brett gardner and the yankees take a
two-nothing lead
gardner splits the gap the other way
outstanding job
of staying on that pitch and here comes
higashioka can the yankees have first
and second with nobody out and stanton
coming up
stanton hits that in the air to center
field and
wow watch it fly my goodness
what a bomb from john carlos stanton
the three-run homer is a tool again for
the bombers
after two swings and misses on sliders
the third one is charm
this one's up a little bit more stanton
makes the adjustment
just once i'd love to know what that
feeling right there is like he knew
right away
yankees five twins nothing polanco
here's a drive right field deep to the
corner
and go on a whole run polanco with his
seventh of the year and the twins are on
the board
well after quite a few off-speed pitches
in this at-bat he challenged him with a
3-1 fastball and as we see polanco do
from the left side a lot
power to the pole side and this ball got
out of here in a hurry
wouldn't you want to get out donaldson
after all that happened please
now here's the 2-2 cole wins the battle
again donaldson
fanned and that was 91 right on the
corner
for stanton that 118 mile an hour double
and then the homer following two hits
last night
starting to lock in stanton powers that
to right field and deep he has
another john carlos stanton
with home run number two on the night a
two-run
shot and a yankees lead is 7-1
eight runs last night seven so far
tonight
and duhar cranks that high
deep and go make it
five home runs in eight games for miggy
the notorious m-i-g and it's 8-1 yankees
cole gets the sign ready to go one and
two to sano
high fly right field back is judge
looking up it's gone a home run so
hitting his 12th and it's home run derby
here at target field
donaldson wondering about cole's drop in
spin rate as last time out
cole called it low hanging fruit
donaldson sky high to right is retired
for the third time tonight
by cole no drama deal two swinging a
miss
struck came out strikeout number nine
for cole
miggy batting with second and third and
duhar
flies that into left center celestino
has an outstanding arm it's going to be
tested here
and archela scores odor to third
a sacrifice fly for miguel and duhar and
the yankees lead is 9-2
now 2-2 cal 2
and so laces one down the right field
line it'll be just
a single but he hit it hard to the
opposite field to drive in a run
yeah home run to right single to center
here
rbi single to right hard hit ball
i know we've we've said this a few times
is this when he gets starts to get
rolling starts to get hot but
a good sign when he's hitting the ball
hard the other way
almost identical to the pitch that
kiriloff hit maybe this one just a
little bit higher but
a nice job of just taking his hands that
ball staying on top of it if he tries to
lift this ball it's going to be a pop-up
or a foul ball or
you can swing under it but instead focus
on staying on top and going direct to
that ball
0-1-2 to roberto celestino
and there it is a bullet to center ceno
will be held at third and celestino
as his first big league head everybody
on the top step of the dugout yes
thank goodness and he can breathe again
there you go what a feeling
the crowd here i guess maybe it's better
to wait for this moment for this crowd
for the crowd to acknowledge this right
here
good for him i got chills right now
that's uh no matter what the score is
the moment he'll never forget maybe a
little longer than he wanted but
still gets to enjoy it the same here's
polanco click rolls to the backstop
so noah's going to try to score and he
will and celestino goes to second
a wild pitch and the twins have a couple
here in the night
wild pitch blanco batting and a deep
drive to right down the pole
and it hits the pole polanco's second
home run
and it's a four-run inning he's just got
a little bit more interesting
maybe a little too little too late but
either way a good time from polanco
another ball driven to right field
frisky a chance to make donaldson the
final out of the game
scott in the air to right frazier is
there
ball game the yankees win it 9-6